I think we've been programmed quite a
bit with our relationship with money and
we have a relationship with everything
known in our environment you have a
relationship a neurological Network in
your brain for your parents for your
cell phone for your computer where you
live where you've lived in the past what
you're going to do tomorrow for the most
part the brain is a reflection of
everything that we know so along with
that is our relationship with money I
feel like I have a really good
relationship with money because I work
on having a really good relationship
with everything in my life if you always
have a good relationship I think so I
think so I've never really lived in lack
that just wasn't part of it even when I
went to college and I had to take out
student loans and stuff I always figured
out a way to always be a little bit
ahead of the Curve hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit on
my business partner I was making 300
bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from some of the best and pick up how to
attract the things we want into our
lives enjoy
let's back up and just look at how
people form beliefs because yes most
beliefs are created from past
experiences right so children when
they're in their early ages their brain
waves are very slow like their brain
waves are in Alpha when they're like
seven to twelve they're in Theta when
they're like two to six years old and
and they're in Delta like when they're
when they're you know newborn to two
years old and so these brainwave States
uh are states that were really
suggestible to information so when we
hear information we believe it and we
accept it we believe it we surrender to
it as if it's the truth without
analyzing it because there's no
analytical facilities yet right the
analytical mind starts around 12 or so 7
to 12 and that analytical mind is
actually what creates a barrier between
the conscious mind and the subconscious
mind so 412 roughly what we see how we
model our parents behavior is all being
programmed subconsciously right and so
so that's really really important
because if you heard money is the root
of all evil
uh money is bad only certain people are
allowed to make money you have to work
hard to make money this is how you got
to do it and
that becomes the foundations
subconsciously like let's like write
recording an audio file you just keep
recording that audio file it becomes a
subconscious program right so a lot of
people have a relationship with money
based on either what they've been told
or what they've experienced in their
outer environment right so
so then we gain information from our
environment and the stronger the emotion
we feel from experiences in our lives
the more altered we feel inside of us
the more the brain freezes a frame and
takes a picture and that snapshot is
called the memory So based on an emotion
based on emotion the emotion Alters our
internal state so you're going along as
Lewis feeling really good and all of a
sudden you have this trauma you have
this crisis you have this shock and all
of a sudden you have this dramatic
change in your internal State and your
senses get heightened and then you
freeze the frame and you associate this
internal state with whatever it is
that's causing it right and that's how
we create long-term memories right so
our painful memories more uh powerful or
beautiful memories more powerful uh
they're both equal okay they're both
equal but but the problem is I think
most people experience from more than
negative the emotions right and those
are negative emotions really are derived
from the hormones of stress right so the
alarm system the emergency system
creates an arousal you know inwardly and
that arousal saying there's something
dangerous in your outer environment
right and it could be a person a
circumstance an accident or whatever and
that that change in emotional state
causes you remember the event you gotta
pay attention right you got to stay
really and narrow your focus on the
cause
so so think about people who have
relationships with money right from the
past with all beliefs are based on past
experiences so you have an experience
where you lose money you have an
experience where money's taken away from
you have an experience where you don't
have enough you're living in a place
where there's not enough money or a
family that's not enough money then the
emotion that most people are living by
in a moment-to-moment basis is lack like
I'm in lack of having something that I
want okay now there's nothing wrong with
that because the experience changes your
emotional state you freeze the frame you
take a picture the problem is
that's hardware so we think
neurologically within the circuits of
that past experience and we feel
chemically within the boundaries of that
emotion which would say for example be
lack right so now the person says before
you go on to the next thing what happens
to the body and the mind when it is in
an environment of lack mentally or
physically I'm in lack what is what is
the body to mind saying yes so the body
is saying I'm waiting
for some external event to occur
I win the lottery I marry the right guy
whatever it is that you're waiting for
that event to occur that experience
produces an emotion so the emotion then
takes away the lack
and so when we play the game in
three-dimensional reality the creation
game in three-dimensional reality we
experience separation from everyone and
everything because our our senses fool
us into the illusion the hallucination
of Separation I'm here and you're there
I'm here and the door is over there so
I'm aware that I'm here at one point of
Consciousness and the door is over there
another point of Consciousness okay so
in order for me to get from here to the
door I gotta move my body and do
something through space I gotta do
something and everything in this
three-dimensional reality is going to
take time and energy right so okay so
then here's here's Lewis right here and
then he says okay I want this experience
in my future and your brain
automatically predicts and projects how
far in the future you think it's going
to take maybe it's a year five years ten
years 30 years oh my gosh right because
that's what it's going to take to pay
off that house right so now one point of
Consciousness I'm here the other point
of Consciousness is where I'm placing my
dreams so I mean separate from that
experience so then how do I get to that
experience in three-dimensional reality
you got to get up and you got to do
something you gotta go to work you gotta
drive to work it takes energy you got to
fill your car with gas you got to eat
food you got to work you know all the
stuff you gotta sleep you got to recover
with your stress and now people are
in a sense waiting for the experience
that's 10 years down the road or 30
years down the world to happen to take
away the lack of them not having it and
unfortunately many times when the
experience finally occurs they can't
enjoy it because they're too exhausted
right so then so you play the game you
you you go to school you study really
hard or you study on your own you
develop some skills you make the right
choices you start saving money you start
learning from your mistakes and then the
game is how many things can you
accumulate and that accumulation then
you associate with being wealthy or
being abundant or being successful right
and some people get really good at it
right you can get really good at that
rule number two is visualize the little
steps with Mel Robbins step number two
for manifesting properly according to
science is you must visualize the steps
that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal this is a major mistake
that people make they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal if you've ever made a
vision board think about what you put on
the vision board you put up just the
beach house or the million dollars in
the bank are you crossing the Finish
Line are you launching that business are
you having the body that you want or you
would drive in the Maserati whatever it
is the end goal is what you put up on a
vision board that is not what you're
going to do when you manifest if you
start focusing on crossing the finish
line of the marathon that is a one-way
ticket to being unmotivated and
completely discouraged in fact research
shows that if all you do is focus on the
thing that you want and you just focus
on that vision of you and your bikini
body or you with the love of your life
on your arms or you at the Oscars
winning that award or the Grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal you start to
feel really unmotivated and discouraged
because you're nowhere near it that's
where manifesting comes in because we're
not going to focus on the end goal you
got to pick something that you want in
order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end it's about the
bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a Grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to Fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be but when it comes to
manifesting once you've given yourself
permission to dream with the lid off and
really want what you want to feel the
pull of that thing now we gotta talk
about the path that connects where you
are with where you want to go and this
is all about visualizing the Little
Steps there's a lot of research that
proves why visualizing the steps is the
most important thing that you could do
there was a study done at UCLA for
example where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a closed
their eyes visualize in their mind and
feel in their body
themselves taking the test and then
walking up to a board where the tests
scores were posted and finding their
name and seeing an A plus that's what
group a the vision board group we're
told to do to visualize themselves
achieving what they wanted
Group B
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room sitting down at the desk
and studying and staying up late and
putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it Group B
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered Group B you got the
correct answer the reason why Group B
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work and it's only through
actions that you will get the result
that you want preparing your mind and
visualizing yourself doing it lowers
your resistance and leads to you taking
the action that's why manifesting works
you know the same is true in sports
there's all kinds of research in sports
psychology in fact our Olympic athletes
for the U.S Olympic team they hire
Sports psychologists to train our top
Olympic athletes particularly after
they've been injured in visualizing
themselves competing when you coach an
athlete to mentally rehearse every
single detail about going through the
competition you are training the mind
body and spirit to show up and dominate
this is is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your pre-competition
feelings about it right so manifestation
properly remember what it is manifesting
is preparing your mind body and spirit
to do the work it's aligning your mind
body and spirit with what you want it
removes the obstacles that would
normally stop you which then prepares
and motivates you to take the actions to
succeed so in the case of athletes who
visualize themselves and see themselves
doing all the steps over and over
they're removing the nerves they're
removing all the programming related to
the injury they are prepared their mind
body and spirit to go in and freaking
Dominate and so are you rule number
three feel the energy with Gabby
Bernstein whatever you came in here
thinking I need that girl I need that
guy I need that money I need that body
Let It Go
I need to assume an energy of what it is
that I want to experience
so if you feel like you've been living
in lack and you've been broke and you've
been going into debt
the work here is to begin to assume the
energy of what it feels to be relaxed
about your finances
the work is to release the fear around
your finances
the work is to begin to celebrate what
you do have and stop looking at what you
don't have and to assume the energy of
abundance regardless of what's going on
in your bank account
if you've come here thinking I'm single
I'm single I'm single I'm 30 I hate
myself I'm single
You Know Who You Are
your work is to start to begin to say
I'm single and I love myself
my first and foremost commitment is to
fall in love with me I am excited about
the relationship I'm building with
myself and assume the energy
of self-love assume the energy of
excitement towards building a
relationship with yourself and release
the lack mentality around Romance
same thing goes with your body start
getting excited about going to the gym
so we're going to get deeper into the
lessons of how we do this but rather
than thinking I need to get that thing
to make me feel better we're going into
a conversation now if I'm going to
assume the energy of already having it
I'm complete I'm whole I'm full with or
without the given circumstances that I
think I need all is good all is well
everybody with me some of you are
thinking but what about the cash
what about the girlfriend
the cash the girlfriend the body it all
shows up folks it all comes it comes in
far greater ways than you could imagine
once you get out of the way once you
stop thinking it's my way or the highway
once you stop thinking I need to make it
happen I had an experience recently with
some friends where we were all sitting
around a table and all I heard around
that table was such a serious lack
mentality there's not enough I can't get
the job I want I can't get the money I
want I can't get the money I need to
support my philanthropic belief systems
I can't I can't I can't I can't I can't
I can't I can't I can't I can't so much
fear so much lack so much lack so much
lack so much lack and I looked at these
people and I said God bless you all but
how do you think that mentality is going
to get you anywhere how do you think
that mentality is going to serve our
economy how do you think that mentality
is going to serve your finances
because it won't
so if you're sitting around the table
saying I can't I can't I can't I don't
have enough I have too much debt I'm in
lack you got to stop it
you got to end the conversation
you may not be able to end dialogue in
your mind right away that's a practice
but you can begin to ask yourself wait
why am I talking
you can use my acronym whenever you want
why am I talking because in those
moments when we catch ourselves being
like Oh my God you know what man
really just can't get that girl right
how is that helping you get the girl
you know what I can't keep that money
and I can't keep that money in the bank
I can't how is that helping you even
conceive of bringing in more so begin to
change the dialogue
become conscious of your actions how are
your actions blocking you from being in
a state and awareness of abundance or
happiness or peace what are your actions
if you want to heal your body but every
day you're walking to McDonald's how is
that serving you
right
if you want to get better at yoga and
manifest a body like Tara Styles in this
room and Sarah Styles in the room
um if you want to have that kind of body
rather than walking to McDonald's every
day go pick up Tara Style's new book I'm
going to plug it right now yoga cures
go pick up yoga cures so whatever it is
that's going on for you right now you
know there's obviously a choice that can
be made that is different than the
choices you have been making and it's
really important for people like myself
to show up in your life in whatever form
we show up whether it's through YouTube
or whether it's through books or through
live lectures to remind you that your
thoughts and your actions are creating
your reality and if you want a different
reality you can have it if you choose to
change your mind your thoughts and your
actions got it
and your words rule number four
eliminate scarcity with Dean graziosi
today I want to talk about the money
mindset and what money means to you
what it what it can mean for you and how
to get more of it
um as simple as that sounds sometimes
actually more than sometimes in so many
cases the thoughts the beliefs the
challenges the frustrations the worry
about money are the exact thing that is
that there are things that are holding
us back from gaining more of it
so I want to spend some time and go
through what I believe will change your
thoughts on money and then at the end
towards the second half I want to go
through ways to create more of it so
let's talk about money money is a weird
thing to talk about to some people we
have this relationship with money like
think about if we were a therapist right
if we were at a therapist then like
money was on one couch and and you were
on the other and the therapist was there
money is one of those things that you
you some people don't like it are afraid
to think about it or don't want to talk
about it too much some people even think
money may be bad or money is evil why
simult while simultaneously it's the
thing that causes the most stress and
worry in their life it's really crazy
it's like you desire it
because it'll cause it'll release pain
but at the same time you're kind of
pushing it away so that's 30 000 foot
let's dig in let's get to some
um
let's get to the money relationship and
the beliefs that so many people have and
maybe some of these you don't have so
let me go through four beliefs that I
think are crippling if you have any
ounce of it and we want to spin those
today so number one money is scarce
we've all been told that money doesn't
grow on trees and what that is is we
feel that money is scarce or in fact uh
we live in a fear that it's going to run
out or going to vanish and we know that
money doesn't vanish money's not going
away there's the same amount of money if
not more around the world than there's
ever been it's not getting smaller think
about that like really think what I just
said money is not shrinking right in
fact
this year America alone and I've said
the stats a lot of you have heard this
but because it boggles my mind that
there's 1700 new millionaires being
created every day in America
think about that 1700 new millionaires
every single day in America what happens
is when we think about money is scarce
and it doesn't go on trees and we have
this feeling that it's getting shrinking
and it's going away what we ask
ourselves is this
how do I protect myself how do I save
this money how do I make sure no one
takes what I have
and that mindset keeps you on the
sidelines
I want you to say what about asking
yourself a different question because
here's the thing if money
doesn't disappear if we know it's the
same amount or more can we agree on that
if it's not disappearing then all it is
is money is moving from one group of
people to another group of people same
amount of money if they're still let's
say there's a hundred dollars and you're
moving it around amongst a bunch of
people it's just who's getting the chunk
of it there's still a hundred dollars
the same sum total is there it's just
moving differently so the question you
should be asking yourself is not how do
I hold on to what I have how do I make
sure I don't lose any of this how do I
make sure you know I I keep the lights
off at night I'm not saying you
shouldn't be conservative what I'm
saying is instead of having that mindset
what we should be saying is how do I
become the person and this is one write
this down I hope you I hope you're
paying attention here today guys I hope
you're not playing with social media
looking around trying to focus on this
because the question should be how do I
become
the person where the money is moving to
rather than away from
right just a same little same thought
process just a different shift instead
of instead of thinking money is scarce
and it's going away even though there's
1700 new millionaires a day in America
alone being created right now money's
not getting scarce it's just those
people money is Flowing to them and
somebody else who's standing there
trying to protect the little protect
themselves and and being thinking is
scarce mindset their money is slowly
going away now I am surely not going to
be an advocate
or say that you shouldn't be
conservative that you shouldn't save
money that you shouldn't be smart with
your money of course you should but
here's what I know
in the evolution of my life of going
from that kid living in a bathroom with
my dad and not having money and all
those things and I'm not saying that to
give you my my my my pitch or my story
but when I look back at when I tried to
save and be conservative because I
listened to you know maybe grandparents
that went through the depression or
listened to people that you know is like
you're crazy what I realize is when you
change your mindset on money
when you gain the capabilities
and when you take action it is
in my opinion you could disagree with me
in my opinion money is easier to flow to
you and make it than it is to save it I
even look at that in my business I'm
like hey let's tighten up on expenses
and I'll look through all these things
like okay if we tighten up all those
because we're such a big company now we
could save this much but if we if I
write a new book if I start a new
campaign if I do some more real estate
deals I can bring in this much with a
little with the same amount of effort
like save this much or just make this
much how the hell with it keep everybody
there keep the lights on I'm gonna go
make it over here now I might be an
extreme but I'd like to give you a
little bit of that that if we stand on
the sidelines envying those making more
being not jealous but like Desiring what
other people have but we're afraid
because we want to hold on to what we
have and be afraid to take action a lot
of times those opportunities pass Us by
let's look at number two we believe if
we make it
that were taking it from others or
hurting others
and that's so false
but I want you to dig in and I'm not
going to go deep on this one I just want
you to think about that because I will
talk to people who are just anti-money
they want to be in it's it's it's this
like two forces fighting inside their
body they want to start their own
business they want to be a capitalist
they want to be an entrepreneur they
want to take ownership of their life
they want to be in control while
simultaneously they feel bad because
they feel like if they're making too
much of it they're actually taking it
from other people
they're not you're not in fact I want
you to have a new thought process on
that when you make money if you want to
change the world if you want to make an
impact on your family if you want to
make an impact on your church if you
want to make an impact on those that
need it those in Houston right now those
in Florida right now are those
struggling in the midwest or those
struggling in Mexico or around the world
or build a school in Africa
you have a desire you have a an
obligation to make money and in fact
when you make money you help the world
Thrive if you get the economy in your
house thriving and you get that security
and confidence and feel like I'm
freaking safe no matter what I'm making
enough to live the lifestyle I want I'm
safe you get to impact other people now
let's take it to another level you start
making more money or you actually taking
it from people or if you get the economy
in your house going and then you're
flourishing your house
do you maybe hire someone to take care
of your lawn do you hire someone to take
care of your house do you hire someone
to make meals for you do you drop off
more dry cleaning do you get a new car
do you maybe upgrade in a house do you
start leaving the air condition lower do
you get a personal trainer do you get a
naturopath do you get a nutritionist
when you make money you help the world
grow this is the complete opposite it's
completely false to think that if you
make money you're hurting someone else
when you make money and change the
economy in your house you can change the
economy and affect the world someone who
doesn't have a job mowing a lawn right
now could have a lawn mowing company or
business if you get out there and make
more money and start spending it also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you you space
to write down what your key takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet design specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number five
understand the mind with Bob Proctor I
want to ask you about uh money and
relationships yeah you you've been
around the block a long time
um
you've seen a lot you've met a lot of
people you've you've had many different
relationships in your life uh
how important is it to have
alignment around money mindset when
you're in an intimate relationship with
your intimate partner or a business
partner
what conversation should we be having
around money to make sure that the
partner we're in business or life with
is going to support us as opposed to be
a you know kind of thorn in the side of
energy if you will well
I think money plays a very very big role
in our life
we should control the money we should
never let money control us I love
earning it
I love giving it away too
um
if you're in a relationship
um
understanding money in the relationship
plays a very big role you can't have one
person with a let's say a poverty
Consciousness and another one with the
prosperity Consciousness and expect to
have Harmony and that relation is just
not going to be there because there's
too many things where money comes into
involved in the decision making and
conversations
and if you're not on the same page
there's trouble in River City you know
in The Music Man you
um
and that's just the way it is so I think
it's very important
but
the truth is not many people understand
money
very few
you know
I was mentioning my business partner
Sandy Gallagher she was a Securities
attorney
when I first met her she came to a
seminar
and she ended up being my business
partner she owns 50 of the company and
she's the CEO of the company she runs it
but she's a damn genius when it comes to
money
on um I have a pad here where I write
things I'm grateful for
the very top things Sandy's financial
genius that's number one
in uh my gratitude list every day
um
I've earned millions and millions of
dollars
but
it wasn't until she until she became a
business partner
about 15 years ago I guess
um that everything in my life changed
with money
because she knew how to manage it
and if you don't know how to manage it
you're not going to do very well
yeah
I how do we first uh manage it in our
minds and not let ourselves become
afraid of it or hoard it or well that's
where it's got a scarcity it's got to
start everything starts in the mind
U.S Anderson said thought is the
preamble to everything
he said when we fully realize that
thought causes all we'll know there's
never any limits that we ourselves don't
impose
everything starts in thought so if you
want order with money it starts here
relationship starts here your business
starts it all starts in your mind
and the problem is Louis hardly anybody
understands the mind
and it's something that can be
understood I oddly enough
I teach it to psychiatrists
and
I'm very good at it that's my strength I
really understand the mind
mind is movement mind's not a thing your
brain isn't your mind anymore your
toenail is
your brain is an electronic switching
stations
um mind is movement
body is a manifestation of that movement
so if you just stand and just observe a
person you'll get a hell of a good idea
what's going on in their mind
foreign
walk by a person just I'll feel their
energy
because you send off
energy
I'll feel I can tell what state they're
in in seminars I'll read a person's
energy I'll scare them
because you have an intuitive Factor you
can pick that energy up and read it
you know but everything starts in the
mind so whatever benefit or
any any good that you want
um that's where it starts you gotta
start to understand it
study it rule number six have fun with
Big Sean what's been the most recent
thing you were talking about learning
life's lessons what do you think has
been the most recent life lesson big or
small that's come across your path
that's kind of stayed with you or been
on your mind I just wonder because
you know we always talk about learning
lessons through life and people think
that they have to be these huge big ones
but sometimes it's just something every
day but what's it been for you has there
been anything that stood up yeah to have
fun nice yeah to make everything you're
doing fine period because we're here for
such a limited time and when we see
somebody pass away that's close to us or
someone we idolize Our Heroes our family
members our friends whatever just you
know you gotta realize that okay
I do work but I need to make this fun
because that is the key to
happiness right and I feel like that is
to me
the only thing that really that's real
success is when you're happy so you got
to have fun with whatever you're doing
like you have to and if it's not fun you
got to make it fun or do something else
you know even if it pays your bills or
anything like you gotta like if you just
approach it like that
I'm telling you to hold something that
may be so depressing to you can
completely change that job you may have
been working on I've been doing this
since I was 11 years old by the way
making music you know and obviously I
want to do other things with my life
like I mean you were so I want to write
a book I can't wait for that yeah
because you know I've learned so many
lessons like from you or from Deepak you
know I get to sit with side Guru and
from your mother my mom especially I get
to sit with Janae I get to sit with all
these amazing I get to sit with Marie
Diamond I get to sit with a lot of
people who know so much and that I know
that it's one of my life purposes to to
put that information into
you know and all the experiences I've
been through all the Testaments I've
seen all the just magic that I've
witnessed in my life you know that's the
reason I want to write a book I'm not
doing it because oh it's a cool thing
for your career to do like write a book
like I feel like I have to write a book
because it's like one of my missions for
Humanity I want to read that book man
yeah I I think it's fascinating hearing
about everyone's journey to how they
started going inward yeah right like
that's what's fascinating yeah like we
always books are always written about
the journey outwards what did you
succeed what did you achieve where did
you get to but to me books that are
about the journey inward right we need
to tell those stories because those are
the journeys we struggle to take even
more yeah and those are the journeys
that are a little bit more Untold right
yes yeah unseen that we need to relate
to and especially my people who listen
to me like I feel like I really need to
do that and but that is one thing I've
learned though to just to go back to
what you said is like to have fun with
it make sure you have fun with it and
make it fun
like bring whatever you think is fun to
whatever you have to do like if you
think well I think vid playing video
games was fun well then bring that to
work somehow like figure out a way to
like incorporate that or figure out a
way to balance that into your life
somehow like you can't let go of the fun
of anything because then everything just
gets depressing yeah you know you get
wiped out and you're not even doing a
service to anyone at that point yeah and
I think that's the interesting thing
it's a simple lesson though right it's a
beaut but that's what I love about it
yeah rule number seven contribute more
with Brendan burchard I grew up with
nothing but I grew up with total
abundance
you know what I mean sometimes you don't
have to have any money to make life fun
or fulfilling or engaging and sometimes
even when you don't have money you can
make things work out you know my parents
work so hard between the two of them I
have no idea how they raise this for
kids I honestly have no idea it blows my
mind and I lucked out yeah I lucked out
on the parent train but still some
people say well yeah yeah you had it so
lucky later on you know later on I went
bankrupt chasing my dream trying to be a
writer trying to be a trainer trying to
do videos like this just went completely
bankrupt ass over detail I mean total is
that a saying I don't know do people
even say that anymore but I was
struggling went back up and what do I do
how do you how do you overcome that well
you begin with yourself not your bank
account because look if your self-worth
is low your value in the marketplace
will always be as low if you don't value
yourself no one else is going to Value
you so you have to first realize that
you have something to contribute even if
you don't know what that contribution is
yet that if you're really going to go to
another level of financial success in
life you have to get dialed in and own
the reality okay whatever mess you're in
or challenge you're in right now it is
your job it is on your shoulders to fix
it you might need to get some help you
might need to get some training you
might need to get some support but it's
your job to write the ship nothing is
going to suddenly emerge and you're not
going to win the lottery we're not going
to get lucky at this there's only two
things that change your life either
something new comes in so yeah maybe you
win the lottery you get an inheritance
and things turn around but the second
thing that changes your life is
something new comes from within
you get a greater hunger a greater
passion a greater commitment to go out
there and crush it again you know go add
so much value that you can't help but
get paid for it a lot of people say well
Brandon I just want to make some money I
said great what do you have to sell
and they say what say you can't make no
money if you get your island in the sale
right you got to have something to sell
so what is it you're offering what are
you selling first and foremost you're
selling yourself you are selling the
ability for you to serve you are selling
your character your ability to offer
something valuable to the world and when
I say selling obviously I don't mean
you're selling out I mean you're
offering yourself you're persuading the
world that you have something to
contribute that you're a hard worker
that you care you're going to get it
done and if you can't do that you can't
grow you can't invest you can't build
you know you have to find that power
from yourself to be able to change
things around and once you find it from
yourself then you have to something to
offer right do you have a product a
program a service to offer to the world
if you're an entrepreneur a business
owner if you do how well have you dialed
in the offering of that product program
or service of the world is your
messaging type is your marketing world
class is your distribution your
capabilities your customer service all
world last year if not keep dying those
in as you dial those in you bring in
more money what if your employee well if
you're an employee it's time to look
around again to check back into that
company what if you're going to get
fired in five days and they're going to
choose who's gonna get fired based on
who is willing to learn the most and who
has been willing to contribute the most
you need to start contributing way
outside of what is put on your desk
every single day or what shows up in
your inbox you need to actually push
away from your inbox push away from your
desk and think how could I add more
value here and that has to be something
you do every day you have to be obsessed
with serving you have to be obsessed
with contributing more than anybody else
you got to bring more ideas to the table
people say well Brandon what if I get
shot down with my ideas So what at least
you flew
at some point you have to be make the
decision to contribute to do if you're
going to get fly if you're going to fly
and you're gonna get shot down then you
gotta shut down at least you lived you
know go contribute more at work look
around who else could you help who else
could contribute to who else could you
mentor and bring up how can you become
the linchpin in the organization in some
way or another to keep climbing and
serving and adding value you deserve
that because at a minimum that's what
makes employment or work fun you know
taking care of people adding value
giving new ideas and if you're one of
those people you don't understand I have
this bad boss or I have to look I've had
terrible bosses in my life too and got
over it maybe you're in the wrong job
some people are in they've you know
they're busy at work but their busy work
isn't their life's work they're doing
the wrong thing they knew they should
have got out there five years ago but
they never had the guts to face
themselves in the mirror and say today
is my day I make the decision to leave
so if you're in the wrong thing
face it at some point because you're
never going to make a lot of money in
the wrong thing and if you do make a lot
of money in the wrong thing then you're
more likely to start doing the wrong
things makes sense right because there's
no meaning there there's no significance
there there's no real contribution you
just you made some money doing the wrong
thing so now you start turning into that
character that just starts pursuing
money just for the ends of money
life should be incredibly valuable to
you if you really value your days like
that day becomes valuable so because
your day is valuable you get stuff done
you know why a lot of people end up
feeling really broke is because they're
not valuing their day they're broke
because they added no value to their day
they were reading celebrity gossip
magazines they were screwing around
online they were doing nothing that
actually moved the needle in terms of
their personal progress and their
professional progress so value this day
you want to make more money get serious
about tomorrow value that day ask how
you can add more value into the day
really work the day and as you do that
over and over and over again you ask how
can I serve how can I contribute how can
I take it to the next level you do that
long enough
the Breakthrough happens the magic
happens and the money takes care of
itself rule number eight make gratitude
your habit with Marie forleo my question
today is about my money mentality you
see I recently became aware that I'm
surrounded by poor people what I mean is
everyone in my life at the moment has a
poor person mentality including me it
feels like my family friends and even my
partner are stuck in scarcity they're
scrambling for dollars stressed out
about bills complain about the
government stealing from them and say
everyone's got their hands in your
pocket it's gotten to the point where
movies are out of the question date
nights don't exist and there are no more
nice dinners it sucks so my question is
how do you break out of the scarcity
mentality when everyone around you is
stuck in it should I cut everyone off
and move to Greenland or do I have to
constantly read books about money help
love Elise Elise this is an awesome
question and you are so not alone not
many people I know grew up with wealth
whether that's actual cash or an
abundant money mentality now here is the
good news you can totally break out of
your scarcity mentality and create a
shift in the energy around you without
moving to Greenland now I know you put a
lot of emphasis on the people around you
but as you know the only person you can
change is yourself so that's where we
gotta Focus here are six ways to turn
that money frown upside down number one
you gotta write yourself a fat reality
check Elise I know you probably know
this but let me remind you almost half
the world that's like three billion
people live on less than two dollars and
fifty cents a day and eighty percent of
all Humanity lives on less than 10 bucks
a day now I did a little research on you
and I'm pretty sure you don't fall into
either one of those populations now I'm
not making you wrong for wanting more
but you gotta get that true abundance
starts with appreciating everything you
already have right now so if you want
out of that scarcity mentality you got
to start appreciating what you got and
make it a habit you've got a roof over
your head you have clean running water
and you have some damn cute clothes I
think Oprah said it best when she said
be thankful for what you have you'll end
up having more if you concentrate on
what you don't have you will never ever
have enough
number two get an ATM
what steal a cash machine
[Music]
no silly girl it's an automatic
transformative Mantra that's just a
simple phrase you put on automatic
repeat that transforms your money
mindset this is something I personally
use to overcome my own scarcity
mentality around money and I still use
it to this day here it is anytime you
part with money whether you're paying a
bill or you're buying something say this
there's always more where that came from
this might sound silly but there is real
power in the words that we say to
ourselves and immense power and rituals
it's a super simple way to retrain
yourself in the truth with a capital T
about money number three byol bring your
own luxury who says he can't have nice
dinners at home in fact I actually
prefer to eat at home my meals taste way
better they are so much healthier and
they cost a fraction of the price you
can take any inexpensive dinner and make
it a nice dinner if you played it
beautifully and you light some candles
and you put on some music and you wear
something nice with just a little bit of
effort you can take a cheap dinner and
make it an amazing dinner in fact one of
my favorite resources for budget
friendly recipes is this magazine
Cooking Light number four start a fun
fund before we go any further I gotta
say you and your partner have got to get
on the same page about money now you
can't change your family or your friends
but it is vital that you and your man
get and stay on the same page regarding
finances you can make busting out of
your scarcity mentality something you
work on together and the fun fund can
help here's what that is it's a checking
account or a piggy bank or a pickle jar
that's earmarked for fun and fun only so
that money is exclusively for movies or
meals out or other things you and your
partner might normally say we can't
afford number five build your knowledge
bank now you said do I have to keep
reading books about money and my answer
until you get your money game together
yes and whether it's books or seminars
or audios it's not just about reading or
listening but you actually have to
implement it especially if you want to
have money and keep it now as for money
seminars they can be a little cheesy and
people may try and sell you some more
stuff but that doesn't matter you'll
still learn a ton and what's even more
important you're going to be around
people who are actively improving their
own money mentality number six is spread
the wealth so this is another strategy
that I've personally use and it's a
little bit counter-intuitive so anytime
you're feeling a lack around money
you've got to give some away and number
nine the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is keep your mind
like a mirror with sad Guru depending on
your design is that's where your mind is
isn't it
isn't it
how do you say this in Hindi wherever
your desire is
that's where your mind is isn't it
what's design
good job
so wherever your desire is that's where
your mind will be
if you desire something intensely your
mind will be always there right now you
desire the cup wrong place to be
you desire a goal that's what you should
desire when you're on the field isn't it
now you can desire the cup
but once you're on the field you just
desire the goal and goal and go nothing
else once your desire is strong your
body and mind naturally moves in the
direction isn't it whatever you desire
that's where you go
if your desire falls off then you can't
keep the mind on it
you just have to develop the icha in you
the only itcher is to score the call
then you don't have to worry about
mental focus that's where the mind will
be
[Music]
can somebody take your mind off what you
desire
can somebody take your mind off what you
desire
what you desire is where your mind will
naturally go isn't it
so how does yoga help in this
see what are the simple parameters with
which the body and mind is functioning
complex machinery
this is the most sophisticated machine
in this planet is human body and mind
isn't it
everything that we have created has come
out of this mind so this mind is a
complex missionary
very complex
[Applause]
so if you do anything wrong it will
create many distractions with
there are some simple ways there is some
simple technology with which you can
keep your mind in a certain condition of
clarity where it's increases that you
learn to keep your mind like a mirror it
simply shows you what is there it
doesn't distort
the moment your mind gets identified
with many things now you are playing as
an Indian hockey player now you get all
distorted because now you're reading the
whole history the glory of Indian hockey
the depths of Indian hockey everything
will flow in your mind now you will not
play the game you will not see the game
the way it is first of all learning to
keep the mind like a mirror
where it simply shows you what is there
in front of you without any distortion
once there is no Distortion you will
walk to the best of your ability isn't
it
now you're walking on this floor there
is no Distortion in Your Vision you can
see everything clearly to the best of
your ability you will go isn't it in
your very Vision if there is distortion
you will unnecessarily stumble all over
the place
so whatever talent you have whatever
capability you have if it has to find
full expression your mind doesn't come
in between and distort anything it just
shows you everything the way it is
so the whole yogic system is focused on
this for a spiritual purpose which can
also be used for the sport that it shows
you everything just the way it is not
some other way not the way you think it
is
I used to struggle a lot with
manifesting just the idea of it I would
watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying I
didn't I just didn't understand it what
was manifest in a lot of attractions
like what are they saying I don't
understand the words that are coming out
of your mouth and I would rewind and
watch again it's like I don't get it I
don't understand I don't I don't
understand and it seemed weird silly not
good enough for me to just sit on the
couch and think about money coming into
your wallet or whatever it was that
you're trying to manifest you got to go
do something that in law of attraction
you know action is at the end of
Attraction like you got to go off and do
the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
color of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your particular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car a new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with and as soon as I
came up with an idea I was like oh you
can't do that or I had to have the
perfect Plan before I would ever take
any kind of action on it and you know
just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
let's say you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
came up with an idea as long as it's in
you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust it it's to write it and then
go do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one particular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and just 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you
and the more that's going to show up
does that make sense so whatever it is
that you are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something I
would tell other people you know like oh
yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a speaker
in front of 70 000 people
because because it I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big
but to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy David but look
I've got I've got a belly or I've got a
you know whatever I'm I'm I am healthy I
am healthy and and visualizing yourself
being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that I judged and
that I didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to attract things with Joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if you're alive
in this world and you haven't been
experiencing the quickening I mean I
mean you know I said to uh someone the
other day
the day where you end your day and Feel
Complete because you finished all your
work